now in West roll you know a lot of
people talk to you about the amount of
nudity in Westworld but I think what's
interesting is it's a very practical
reason for saying no to a merkin I did
say no to my Merkin yes number one to be
honest one of the reasons why they
provided them is because a lot of women
do things to alter what's going on down
there
yeah so I didn't need the Merkin because
I don't alter anything good to know
because it was a period piece we
couldn't have any alterations down
because they weren't doing that back in
you know Chris back in those days in
western you know that time the Prairie
the wide open prairie they weren't
waxing and stripping a little locking
and you know the guys on the stag dues
would have complained they would like
what are you doing down this is so us
are clean accurate
- I said no because it took Ino is
another like 45 minutes to get that
thing glued on and I wanted to go home
to my two-year-old yeah oh yeah I would
didn't want to spend time doing that
yeah is there I know that it's probably
has something to do with historical
accuracy but I think that also isn't
there like you guys I don't you're not
as prudish as we are in the States but
there's something about a rating - right
like for a rated R thing like you've I
remember I've heard there's like
instances where they have to put merkins
on women who would get a bikini wax
because it's a rating thing like you can
see a bush but if you see one with no
Bush then it's like somehow more
salacious and can't pass the rating
thing
[Laughter]
[Applause]
yeah
[Music]
you